this is exciting uh because sona i think
maybe there's something you're okay with
talking about i am just
yeah you are uh would you want to uh all
of america
is listening and by that i literally
mean we're
a very successful podcast okay so in my
mind everyone in america is listening
why don't you tell us what you have to
say
um i'm pregnant
congratulations yay
thank you very much that is so exciting
that is so exciting
i know thank you i have known i've known
for a while but of course
uh and i was proud of myself wow you
can't tell people i
and and you know what i love i'm making
this about me instantly
you weren't you know what though you
were you were i think the first
person besides me and tac to know yeah
uh because
i came to your house to help you with
something and you offered me wine
and i said no i'm not drinking and
you're like are you pregnant
you just immediately asked me and i
think we had found out
the day before that we were you know it
was weird it was nine o'clock in the
morning
and i was drinking out of a bottle of
wine i wasn't even pouring it into a
glass and i was like sona have some
and she said well i don't think what are
you pregnant
what's the due date when does the birth
certificate man come around
that's right it's six months after
the you give birth that you have to get
the same guy
who was four months late for your dad
birth certificate
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to track that guy down and i'm going to
fly him to the united states
so that he can handle your birth
certificate well i don't
i don't think he came because of my dad
he came to the village and he's like
okay what babies were born and then
people were like my baby was bored and
my baby you're like okay all of you have
a february 15th
oh my god that's how they did it do you
think he did
other things too i get the sense that he
he didn't
he sounds like a guy who came to the
village to deliver mail
yeah give you your birth certificate he
probably had a soft-serve machine
you know if anyone wanted ice cream he
sounds like a guy
who did a bunch of things ah um
well we are also uh we're having twins
i know oh i know as a tear scrolls down
that's four birth certificates
oh man good one girly you just hit it
that was the natural you hit it out of
the park it hit the lights and the
lights exploded i'm going on tylenol pm
every day you are so funny when you're
jacked on tylenol
man so sona you're having uh you're
having
twins uh can i ask more questions do we
know the sex
yes uh they're both they're both boys
oh my god no uh yeah
so great it's a lot it's a lot all at
once
uh so we'll never you'll we'll you'll
never we'll never talk to you again
in a couple of months no i don't think
so i
i don't think he will i well some i'm do
do mid july but they'll probably come
early because
twins come early and uh yeah you know we
spend a lot of our time just kind of
sitting here in silence just being like
what
did we what did we do
[Laughter]
and tak keeps asking if he has time to
do his karate
which he does um
yes well guess what let me explain
something to you sona there's called a
hierarchy of needs
yeah priority number one priorities and
so what's gonna happen is tax karate
and i promise you this is going to go
away
i hope he has a sensei that's going like
change diaper and he teaches him wax the
fence but his baby stuff
yeah yeah it's funny if his if his
karate style is all
based like the way mr miyagi's was on
wax on wax off it's all based on
changing
two diapers at once with each hand and
that becomes like the most
impossible fantastic defense attack in
karate
oh my god this is insane i'm so happy
for you
and yeah i know it's very exciting we
yeah we wanted it for a while so this is
exciting it's a lot
i'm thrilled are you uh wow and of
course
uh i knew about this and then you you
you showed me a video of your mom
and your dad being told and you did a
really cute thing you had your nieces
tell her
uh-huh yeah and they're really young i
couldn't believe that they
kept the secret because yeah they're
seven and five
and uh they were bursting to tell them
um and you know my mom has two grand
two granddaughters so she so badly
wanted a boy
and then we told them we were having
twins and then we were like okay
guess the gender and my mom was just
like boy
like she didn't care spilled it into
half and she also did she
i'm gonna back sona up i've seen the
video your mother does it with no joy
she's like really happy that you're
having the baby she's really happy you
say
and then you say it's twins and she's
like oh my god and she's crying and she
sits down and she can't stand up and
then you just say guess the gender and
she just leans forward and she goes
boy like that's i'm not asking
i'm telling you it's this boy
i don't care what the other one is as
long as one is a boy
who cares oh man yeah and then uh
you know my grandpa's 98 and he was in
the video and he's just eating and he
has
no idea what's going on
he just knows everyone's like chaotic
ah that is incredible yeah that's
wonderful that made my day
oh yeah isn't that fantastic it's very
exciting you know i remember just to
give everyone a sense of your mom do you
remember the first thing your mom
said to me when i met her which is now
11 years ago
yeah when you your mom came to the set
of what was in the tonight show
and we hadn't even started the tonight
show yet and you brought your mother
up to say hello to me yeah you were in
you were a new employee and what did she
say
she said you rock the usa
she said you rocked the us i said oh hi
how are you uh mrs mafia and she went
conan you rocked the usa well
no i don't i never have and i never will
but that's a very sweet thing for her to
upset she doesn't like it when i call
you a dick
on tv that's something she brings up all
the time don't
she doesn't like that you disrespect me
yes she hates it i
like that you're regularly doing a
segment called big dick history
she does not listen to the podcast oh my
god i think she'd be horrified
well this is exciting this is really
exciting so i'm just so and i
i i checked with you beforehand because
but i because i
i know i come across as an insensitive
brute but i
do uh want to make sure that
i'm not revealing or making you say
anything about your life that you don't
want to but this is
you you were cool with talking about
this it's really exciting
yeah i mean we're you know we're um tac
doesn't like when we like
post things on instagram so we're not
gonna have like a photo shoot and
post anything so this is pretty much my
only way of like telling people i forgot
to tell so that's
that's it's like killing two birds with
one stone i guess
oh good well so we found a use for this
podcast baby announcement
that's terrific soda it's very
convenient for me
yeah thank you anything else you know if
you want to tell tac what time is karate
class starts yeah you can make that
announcement too
well i just wanted to get i'm so glad
i'm so glad that's out there
what do they say in in uh in armenia
i mean i know that like uh the jewish
people would say like oh mazel tov or
is there any way of saying what do you
say
it means uh like uh light to your eye
light to your eye what you got it's like
your arch
your eye light light in your eye
what's going on over there yeah i mean
birth certificates are coming months
late and then the way you
and then the way you i mean you know in
this country
applying light to someone's eye is a
neurological exam it's a way of telling
if you've been injured
so if you want to congratulate someone
you could theoretically just shine a
flashlight in their face
i guess i don't know archicad
that's good yeah
that's good you don't you said lice that
was bad
i speak fluent armenian what are you
talking about oh yeah
okay my friend kev work i forgot
you just said a name yeah and you guys
repeated the same thing over and over
yeah
uh cher arpie at meccan i went to high
school with her
share share that's what i say constantly
you know what's funny since go since
knowing sona and famously knowing sona
everywhere i go armenian people are like
conan
and i and then i go i go vince possec
and then go love him
and uh now i can say what is it light in
your eye
light in your eye louise
and then i can say share oh you don't
have to say
share why she's armenian you're just
gonna yell out armenian people
oh i'm not going to mention the
kardashians oh that's probably
for the best i think so i think share's
the better way to go
all right well congratulations very
happy thanks guys
really happy really if that's not a
segment i don't know what is